salutations I'm Walter Brennan and this
is top five here we countdown the best
and worst performances of our most
beloved actors today we're looking at
the best of this guy yeah yeah stop
cruise there's no way around saying it
Tom Cruise is a legend the 54 year old
is one of the last big movie stars
around who still puts out consistent
quality work he may best be known for
his action roles but Cruise is actually
a really good dramatic actor who has a
very unique personality and screen
presence his newest Jack Reacher never
go back just to theaters this past
weekend so now is as good of a time as
any let's take a look at the top five
best Tom Cruise performances number five
Major William cage in edge of tomorrow
also known as live die repeat edge of
tomorrow is an underappreciated actioner
from 2014 I wasn't a believer until I
saw it myself but if you haven't seen it
I'd suggest checking it out it's more
than just an action version of Groundhog
Day cruise puts in a great mix of
physicality and really interesting
character moments for him to work off of
based on the japanese light novel all
you need is kill edge of tomorrow takes
place on an earth that has fallen under
attack from seemingly invincible aliens
Major William cage an officer who hasn't
ever fought a battle in the war is
suddenly tasked with being a part of the
frontlines to push back the alien
invasion he dies quickly but immediately
wakes up the previous day and is forced
to relive the battle over and over again
until he finds another person who has
experienced a similar occurrence
Cruise's character goes through a big
arc here he starts off as a bit of a
coward but slowly through the time loop
that he experiences he becomes a very
skilled soldier and has to react to an
unbelievable situation believably for a
movie that is all about repeating the
same day it feels fresh on many levels
sergeant Rita vrataski played by Emily
Blunt also helps out this film by being
a 100% badass she has a good
back-and-forth with crews that works
both on the bad
field and in quieter moments you die
here right here I can't save you and if
I go on and kill the Omega you're dead
forever
why does it matter what happens to me
this is a very strong performance from
Tom he gets a lot to do and seeing him
in his usual action mode while dealing
with the effects of adapting to the time
loop combines for one of his best there
is a sequel and development so hopefully
we'll get more of Bill Cage in the
future number four lieutenant Daniel
Kaffee and a few good men this film of
course contains one of the most famous
quotes in movie history delivered by
Jack Nicholson Nicholson is fantastic in
this and was nominated for an Oscar but
Cruz was also pretty good in this too
written by Aaron Sorkin and based on his
play a few good men follows lieutenant
Daniel Kaffee a military lawyer who is
defending two US Marines charged with
murdering a fellow Corps member
Kaffee and his fellow councilmen think
there is a conspiracy to cover up the
truth behind the killing and dig deep
into the US military to find it this is
pretty much classic Tom Cruise he's
confident a little cocky a tad off the
wall but still charming as usual he gets
to show off some of this quirky comedic
timing as well which works out pretty
well for this character go see your wife
see your daughter joke do whatever it is
you do when you're not he eats breakfast
300 yards away from 4,000 Cubans that
are trained to kill him blending in with
that personality is a strong backstory
about his father who was also a lawyer
that element lead to a few noteworthy
scenes I think my father would have
enjoyed seeing me graduate from law
school
I think you would have legs had an awful
lot the best parts of this movie are the
scenes when Nicholson and Cruz exchange
dialog they have some pretty good
chemistry and their tension pops off the
screen you can't handle the truth sweet
dreams son don't call me son I'm a
lawyer and an officer in the United
States Navy and you're under arrest you
son of a bitch
once again this is a classic Tom Cruise
movie with an iconic scene within it and
the performance that Tom Cruise gives is
good enough for the number-4 spot on
this list number three Vincent in
collateral Tom changed his look up a bit
for this role and it's also a bit of a
departure for him because he gets to
play the bad guy Max is an experienced
cab driver with big plans for his future
when he picks up Vincent he soon
realizes he's in for the ride of his
life
Vincent is a hitman who forces max to
drive around LA as he kills witnesses to
a crime max tries to figure out how to
stop him as the police start to pick up
on their trail this was a chance for
crews to shine in a different way that
were used to seeing him he killed it
literally and figuratively as Vincent in
this movie yo homey my briefcase
we all know crews can do the action but
he's appropriately much more brutal in
this
Jamie Fox and Cruz make a nice on-screen
team as they tensely debate about things
even deeper than Cruz killing his
victims
Vincent likes to get personal and this
pulls out uncomfortable facts about
Fox's character as they continue to
analyze each other someday someday my
dream will come whether you wake up new
discovered never happened it's all
turned around on you it's very difficult
to get a read on Vincent you never know
if he's telling the truth that unknown
quality kept me on the edge of my seat
for the entire film for the last act of
this movie Cruz basically becomes the
Terminator and it's something I never
knew I wanted until I saw myself
michael mann directs another great
two-person action drama with collateral
if you haven't seen this one and you're
a fan of his other films i think you'll
really be into it
number two Ron Kovic
in born on the 4th of July based on the
autobiography by the real Ron Kovic
this film features one of the three
Oscar nominated performances from Cruz
he gets to show off a lot of range in
the film about a Vietnam War veteran who
is paralyzed and comes back home to a
country torn apart
patriotic suburban New York teenager Ron
Kovic enlists in the Marines right after
high school and is sent to Vietnam on
its second tour he accidentally kills a
fellow soldier and layer becomes
paralyzed in battle when he returns home
to the States he finds a nation that is
split over the war slowly his depression
over his situation takes hold until he
finds a purpose as an impassioned critic
of the US as involvement in the Vietnam
conflict we first see Cruz as a high
school student and he portrays the
youthful Kovac really well he captures
the awkward nervous mannerisms of
someone that young and in his position
we see his confusion through his
conflict of staying home or going off to
fight what he thinks is a war to save
the world from communism the Vietnam
scenes are especially intense as Kovac
sees the true horrors of war Cruz
realistically reacts to the instances of
mayhem this film shows just how badly
Vietnam War veterans were treated upon
returning home and it gives Cruz
something deep to tap into we see
kopecks youthful optimism slowly fall
away as he accepts his predicament and
falls into a heartbreaking despair this
is not a glamorous part for Cruz to play
he gets down and dirty throughout the
film and we see this man at the absolute
lowest low by the way Willem Dafoe pops
up in this
he didn't even need that Green Goblin
mask
the only thing that kept this out of the
top spot is a couple times when Cruz
kind of seemed like he was trying too
hard these parts don't last long but
they are noticeable upon a close
inspection in any case Cruz really went
all out in this movie and shows us a
portrait of a man who hit rock bottom
and crawled all the way back up Tom
Cruise is indeed a prolific actor and
has a lot of memorable and iconic roles
to his name so before we get to number
one here are some honorable mentions
[Music]
and the number one best Tom Cruise
performance is Ethan Hunt in Mission
Impossible three hear me out in this I'm
not saying this is the best Mission
Impossible movie although it is a
contender but this is the best that Tom
Cruise has been as Ethan Hunt
he's more refined as an actor than in
one-and two-and gets to show a ton more
emotion than he ever did in four or five
mi3 starts with Ethan Hunt being retired
from active duty as he's recently and
happily engaged to his fiancee Julia
however he's dragged back into the field
when an old friend is captured what
ensues involves dangerous black market
dealer Owen Davian threatening
everything Ethan holds dear in the most
violent ways possible
a microcosm of why this is Cruz's best
performance is in the thrilling opening
scene to this film check it out I want
to help you get whatever you want
but you got to do what's right you know
what's right no no no Cruz isn't
invincible in this like he is in four
and five he has a lot to lose and we see
that urgency in them for most of the
movie this is also the most emotional
the series has gotten Cruz's scenes with
his wife are well-placed and add a lot
of depth to hunt this all joins the
standard action beats that we all love
about the Mission Impossible movies but
ups the ante to the enth degree director
JJ Abrams really raised the stakes to a
whole other level this film doesn't take
itself too seriously either as there are
a lot of funny moments that Cruz gets to
be involved
[Applause]
got to mention how amazing Philip
Seymour Hoffman is as the villain here
definitely one of his best roles as he
plays the best bad guy in the mission
impossible franchise he is straight-up
scary he saw what I did you little blond
friend at the factory right
oh that was nothing that was
fun
that's fun
Cruz gets to go up against that for a
lot of the movie and it makes for some
powerful scenes I told her she caught
your name I think the combination of
action heart emotion and comedy equal
Tom Cruise's number one performance
before I sign off today I'd like to
import you to please help out cancer
survivor and one of my friends Barry
piotrowski he beat Hodgkin's lymphoma a
few years ago and was wrongfully
abandoned by his health insurance
company left to pay all his medical
bills by himself Barry is also a
professional wrestler and I made a
documentary about him a few years ago
you can help him by buying this shirt
the link is in the description below
along with a link to the trailer for the
documentary he's one of my closest
friends and did not deserve what
happened to him please help him out if
he can he'll get a cool shirt and you
won't regret it I want to hear what you
guys think what is your favorite Tom
Cruise movie and/or performance who you
want me to cover next in the show leave
a comment and let me know follow me on
twitter at awesome underscore walter and
come back next week when we count down
the top five worst Tom Cruise
performances see you then
[Music]
[Applause]